في عناوين حصاد الليله
في اليوم العاشر على الزلزال في تركيا
اتساع رقعه المناطق المنكوبه بعد ضم ولايه
جديده الى القائمه وفرق الانقاذ تواصل
اخراج نجيم منظمه الصحه العالميه تحذر من
خطر تفشي الامراض المعديه وكاميرا الجزيره
ترافق عمليات ايصال المساعدات الى المناطق
النائيه
في سوريا حصيله ضحايا الزلزال تقترب من
سته الاف قتيل وعلى وقع معاناه ما بعد
الكارثه مطالبات مستمره بتسهيل دخول
المساعدات ويوم الرايتس ووتش تدعو لاعتماد
اليه جديده لادخال المساعدات الى الشمال
السوري
وفي احدث تجليات سياسات اقصى اليمين
الاسرائيلي بحق الفلسطينيين الكنيسه يصدق
على ابعاد الاسرى المقدسيين وسحب الجنسيه
من المتهمين بتنفيذ عمليات والسلطه
الفلسطينيه تعتبر القرار جريمه تطهيرا
عرقي وتصعيدا خطيرا من شانه جر الوضع نحو
الانفجار وحركه حماس تدين القرار وتدعو
الى تحرك دولي ضد مواصفاتها بالقوانين
الاحتلاليه العنصريه
بعد اعتقالات طالت شخصيات سياسيه واعلاميه
المعرضه التونسيه تندد وتدعو القوه
السياسيه الى الوحده الاتحاد الشغل يدعو
الى التعبئه دفاعا عن الحريات والرئيس
سعيد يتهم المعتقلين بالتامر على امن
الدوله والخارجيه الامريكيه تعبر عن قلقها
وتؤكد اهميه وجود نظام قضائي مستقل وشفاف
لحمايه الحريات العامه
السلام عليكم تستمر اعماله ورفع الانقاض
والبحث عن ناجين وانتشار الجثث وترتفع
معها حصيره القتلى اذ بلغت في تركيا وحدها
35 الفا
و488 قتيلا وفق احصاء انكشفت عنه اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه وقد ادى زلزال
بحسب المسؤولين الاتراك الى تهجير مليونين
ومئتي الف شخص بينما نصبت عشرات الاف
الخيام في المناطق المنكوبه لاواء مئات
الالاف الذين اصبحوا بلا ماوى
وبعد عشره ايام من الزلزال المدمر تتشبث
فرق الانقاذ بالامل في العثور على ناجين
وقد تكللت هذه الجهود بالنجاح في انطاكيا
وكرماش وهو ما دفع وزير الداخليه التركيه
للحديث عن امال في العثور على المزيد
لحظات ينتظرها الجميع بفارغ الصبر
رغم مرور عشره ايام على زلزال كهرمان مراش
تخرج فرق الانقاذ امراه وطفليها احياء في
مدينه انطاكيا بولايتها
وهذه امراه في كهرمان مراش مركز الزلزال
المدمر نجت ايضا بعد بقائها تحت الانقاض
ل22 ساعه وهذه المسنه ذات 77 عاما انقذت
بعد تسعه ايام من بقائها تحت انقاض منزلها
في اليمن مشاهد يامل الجميع ان تكثر
وتتكرر بمرور الوقت لملاها من تاثير في
نفوس ذوي الضحايا وهمه ومعنوياتي فرق
الانقاذ
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخراج شخص اخر ما
زال على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاض في
قهرمان مراش وما زال نعلق الامال على
الوصول الى مزيد من الناجين زملائنا في
الميدان يواصلون العمل بكل عزم واخلاص
امثله كثيره النجاه فيها اشخاص بعد مرور
الوقت المقدر فيه بقائهم احياء تحت
الانقاض ومنها رجل بقي حيا بعد 12 يوما
تحت الانقاض التي خلفها زلزالها عام 2010
الثابت ان الامل باخراج احياء لا يخضع
لمنطق الارقام والقياس الى حالات سابقه
ولا ترضمه قتامه مشاهد الخراب فهو دائما
فسحه لا سقف لها ولا حدود
هذا قد درسنا شبكه الجزيره اليه ايصال
المساعدات من قبل القوات التركيه الى
المناطق النائيه بولايه اضنه التي ضربها
الزلزال
نحن الان على متن مروحيه تابعه للقوات
التركيه تحاول ايصال المساعدات الى
المناطق النائيه التي ضربها الزلزال يمكن
من النافذه معاينه التضاريس الصعبه لهذه
المنطقه اي احد سيعاني في محاوله الوصول
الى هذه المناطق
الجزيره يونس ايه ياسين اهلا وسهلا بك
يونس يونس اخر ملامح المشهد
المشهد محمد مرحبا بك المشهد مازال مستمر
يعني جهود الانقاذ والاسعاف ومحاوله البحث
عن ناجين ما تزال تكلل بالنجاح على الرغم
من ان يعني الامل يضمحن مع مرور الوقت نحن
نتحدث عن الان نعيش الساعه التاسعه
والسبعين بعد المئتين وبالتالي الامال
المتضائله بالعثور على ناجين لكن جهود فرق
الانقاذ ومغالبه التعب مغالبه الظروف
والطقس نحن الان يعني درجه الحراره في
غازي عنتاب التي لم تتاثر بشكل كبير
بالمقارنه مثلا مع الولايات كهرمان مرعش
انطاكيا يعني لم تتاثر كثيرا لكن درجه
الحراره منخفضه ومع ذلك فرق الانقاذ مازال
مستمره عمليات الانقاذ في غازي عنتاب حيث
نتواجد عمليا توقفت لانه عدد المباني التي
تضررت قليل جدا بالتالي تم مسحها
الفرق الانقاذ الان يعني تركز على
استخراج المواد
الاساسيه مواد البناء من اجل فتح تحقيق
مستقبلا في
الامكانيه وجود فساد في عمليات البناء
المشهد كما ترى يعني كما تعرضه
الكاميرا محمد هذا المخيم انشاته البلديه
بعد ايام مباشره بعد زلزال القاطنون فيه
ظروفهم قد تحسنت كثيرا بالمقارنه مع مكان
عليه الوضع مباشره بعد الزلزال هذه الخيام
توفر التدفئه الحد الادنى من ظروف العيش
في كل خيمه توجد يعني وسائل تدفئه يتم
توفير الطعام من خلال المراكز التي اعدتها
بلديه غازي عنتاب والتي توفر وجبات بمئات
الالاف لسكان ولايه غازي عنتاب عمليات
التفتيش في المباني التي تضررت يعني قطعت
اشواط كبيره في ولايه غازي عنتاب حيث
نتواجد 70% من عمليات قد تمت وتم تصنيف
المباني حسب تضررها هناك مباني تضررت بشكل
طفيف هناك مباني تضرط بشكل كبير وبالتالي
الان سوف يتم جرد هذه المباني ومعرفه بعد
ذلك هل سوف يتم دعوه السكان بالعوده اليها
ام انه سوف يتم هدمها لانها لم تعد قادره
على استيعاب سكانها
الارقام التي تتصلنا بشكل يعني دوري محمد
تعكس حقيقه شيء ربما لافت الانتباه وهو
انه بعد عشره ايام ما يزال فرق الانقاذ
تنجح في انتشال الناجين اليوم في كهرمان
مرعش يعني تم انتشال سيده تبلغ من العمر
77 سنه وايضا طفل سيده وطفلين في ولايه
هاتايا التي تاخرت فيها عمليات الانقاذ
بالنظر الى وجودها في اقصى الجنوب التركي
ما تزال فرق الانقاذ تنجح ايضا في الوصول
الى ناجين على الرغم من حاله الدمار
الكبيره التي شهدتها هذه الولايه والتي
كنا فيها قبل ثلاثه ايام هو حقيقه المشهد
كان الصادم جدا بالنظر الى وجود احياء
كامله مدمره وهذا ايضا يطرح اشكالات اخرى
مستقبليه فيما يتعلق بالتحذيرات التي
اصدرتها الحكومه التركيه والتي عكستها
ايضا تصريحات منظمه الصحه العالميه من
التحذير من الامراض التي قد تنتشر في
الولايه بسبب الجثث المتحلله التي يعني
توجد تحت الركام والتي يصعب على فرق
الانقاذ الوصول اليها بالحديث عن بروده
الطقس محمد ربما قد تكون هذه نعمه في طي
نقمه لان بروده الطقس قد تحول او قد تؤخر
عمليه تحلل الجثث لكن هذا يبقى خطرا يهدد
سكان المنطقه الذين يفترشون يعني الذين
يعيشون في الساحات ويهدد ايضا اطقم لانقاذ
التي يعني تكثف محاولاتها في في سعيها
للوصول الى ناجين هناك وعود رسميه من
الحكومه التركيه بانها سوف يعني
تقوم بمجهود كبير من اجل اعاده الاعمار
بشكل قياسي خلال سنه حسب الحكومه التركيه
سوف يتم اعاده بناء المنازل المهدمه لكن
هذا تحدي كبير بالنظر الى العدد الكبير
للمنازل المتضرره هناك حديث اليوم عن
خمسين الف مبنى يعني
مهدد بالسقوط وبالتالي قد تلجا الحكومه
التركيه الى يعني هدمها للنظر الى انها لم
تعد قادره على استيعاب ساكنها محمد شكرا
شكرا جزيلا لك يونس سعيد ياسين من غازي
عنتاب
وتاكيدا لما قاله يونس الان فقد قالت
منظمه الصحه العالميه ان نقص المياه في
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال يزيد مخاطر
تفشي الامراض المعديه وقال ممثل المنظمه
في تركيا ان المنظمه تعمل مع السلطات
المحليه على مراقبه الامراض المعديه التي
تنتقل بين النازحين بواسطه المياه وكذلك
الانفلونزا والكوفيد اثر الضرر الكبير
الذي لحق بشبكات المياه والصرف الصحي في
المناطق المتضرره
معنا من اسطنبول السيده ساره الديري رئيسه
فريق الانقاذ التابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الالبانيه اهلا بك سيدتي ما الذي بقي من
دور لفرق الانقاذ الان
فرق الانقاذ طبعا
دائما لاحظوها الامل بانقاذ حياه الناس
هذا هو الدافع الرئيسي لدينا منذر الاول
ورغم ان الاعمال
اقل الان في هذه الايام
لكن ذلك لا يعني ان العمل قد انجز وانتهى
كلا ما زال نواصل بشكل
ليلنا نهار بالقيام بنفس ما نقوم به منذ
فتره
ونواصل البحث وقد وجدنا اشخاص على قيد
الحياه فيهم السابع والثامن والتاسع
وحتى كان هناك طفل ولاده الطفل ولد طفل
اثناء الزلزال اذا في الوقت الحالي
لا نستطيع ان نقول بان قد توقفنا مهامنا
في العمليات الانقاذ
هذا لا يعني اننا نبحث عن معجزات بل لقد
ثبت ايضا
حقائق بان الناس يمكن ان يبقوا على قيد
الحياه حتى بعد ايام عديده من الاسبوع
الاول طبعا كلما مر الوقت كلما قلت فرص
ذلك ولكن على الاقل نحن كمهنيين وما فارق
متخصصه في الانقاذ فان العمل بس ما زال
كما كانوا مستمر مئه بالمئه
بعض الاعمال قد انتهى في بعض المناطق
وبالتالي جرى التنظيف وبعض المناطق وانتهت
ولكن طالما ان هناك
انسان واحد يحتمل ان يكون داخل اي مبنى
فسواء كان اسره وكان ابن عمه وجار فان فرق
الانقاذ لا تتوقف عن عمله اطلاقا الا بعد
ان تجده
هل معنى هل معنى ذلك سيده هديري بانه لا
يوجد تاريخ محدد تقولون فيه انتهينا الان
من عملنا
ليس هناك اي تاريخ محدد
وقد كان
فقد وجد بعض الاشخاص على قيد الحياه بعد
حتى بعد سته عشر يوما من
وهذا حقيقه وكما قلت اننا لا نهدف
الى ان نجعل انفسنا كان نبحث عن معجزات بل
ان لدينا حقائق في السابق ثبت لنا التجارب
السابقه ان هذا امر ممكن
وحتى هناك امل لو كان الامل واحد بالمئه
فاذا تزول هذه الواحد بالمئه يبقى الامل
لدينا قائما الناس الان في فرقنا لم تتوقف
ولن تتوقف في الايام القادمه ايضا الى ان
الى ان يعلن ذلك رسميا ولكن حاليا ليس
هناك اي يوم اخر يوم محدد لا من قبل
المؤسسات ولا من قبل حكومه ولا من القوى
فرق القوات الخاصه حاليا العمل المستمر
مئه بالمئه كما كان في اول يوم شكرا جزيلا
لك السيده ساره الهديري رئيسه فريق
الانقاذ التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الالبانيه
وفي قصصنا الانسانيه التي نسلط فيها الضوء
على يوميات منكوبيه الزلزال واثاره
المدمره استطاع السيد نظيف في مدينه
اديمان انقاذ اطفاله من منزل العائله قبل
ان ينهار بالكامل لكنه فقد نحو 20 شخصا من
اقاربه يروي نظيف بتاثر بالغ قصته مع
الكارثه
خلال الايام الماضيه كثيرا حتى جفت دموعي
لا استطيع التوقف عن البكاء اطلب من الله
عز وجل ان يلطف بنا
عندما شعرت بالاهتزاز بدات اردد الشهاده
وكان المطر ينهمر بغزاره سحبت اطفالي خارج
المنزل ثم عدت واخرجت والدتي ام
ضاء دون ان اعرف من اين تاتي تلك الاصوات
رايت رجلا واحدا فقط سحبت من تحت الحجاره
وقلت له ان يهتم بنفسه واكملت السير وفتش
عن بقيه افراد العائله
الكثيرين خمسه عشر او عشرين شخصا من
اقربائي اسال الله ان يرحمنا جميعا
واقربائنا نحن اربع عائلات من الناجين
نتجمع سويا الحمد لله اننا على قيد الحياه
رعاه
ما يعني
صعوبه في النوم انا في فزع مستمر واعتقد
انني لن استعيد حياتي كما كانت من قبل
سيرافقني هذا الخوف لبقيه حياتي
عضو مجلس اداره منظمه خبيبه التركيه
للاغاثه الانسانيه اهلا وسهلا بك ما او
روايتكم الان في عمليات الاغاثه
حياكم الله شكرا لكم نحن عندنا الاولويه
الان الحاجات المستدامه اي البيوت كما
نقول عنها الكونتينرت
الخيم وادوات التدفئه يعني سواء
الكهربائيه او التي تعمل على الحطب لان
بصراحه هذه الازمه اتت في اكثر الايام
بروده في تركيا في اليوم نحن في الشهر
الثاني شهر شباط ونحن مقبلين على الشهر
الثالث والرابع والخامس هي اشهر ستكون
بارده في بعض المناطق وخصيصا في منطقه
مرعش
وغازي عنتاب واين وصلت اين وصلتم في في
هذه المساله البيوت والخيام وغير ذلك
نحن نحن سواء في المناطق التركيه او في
المناطق السوريه بدانا بدانا بتوزيع الخيم
ولكن البيوت
الكونتينر بعد لم بعد لم نبدا بها ولم
يبدا بها اي جمعيه او اوقاف اخرى سوى يعني
باعداد قليله وقد بدات اول دوله بدات في
ارسال هذه البيوت هي كانت دوله قطر قد
ارسلت تقريبا
يعني هي وعدت بان ترسل 10,000 بيت
وارسلت بعضها والان تقوم بعض الجمعيات
بالتعاون معنا في تامين هذه البيوت
وارسالها لتلك المناطق
بالنسبه للخيام هل هل توجد كفايه خاصه وان
هناك تعليمات للمصانع التركيه بعدم
التصدير في هذه الفتره
وتخصيص كل الخيام
للاغراض المحليه
نعم الدوله قد نزلت الضريبه المضافه على
على مواد الخيم من 18% الى 1%
لواحد في المئه بسبب هذه بسبب حادثه
الزلزال بصراحه الخيم هي ليست حلول دائمه
بل هي حلول مؤقته لايام او اكثر لان الجو
كما ذكرت قبل قليل ان الجو بارد هناك
والخيم لا تصلح للتدفئه او تصلح للعيش
يعني لفترات طويله نحن الان نتكلم عن فتره
اقل شيء سنه فلا يمكن لهذه الناس ان تعيش
في الخيم في خلال ظرف هذه سنه ونحن نتكلم
عن اقل شيء انه ستكون سنه نحن نتكلم عن
فتره اكبر من من تلك
وخصيصا في اشهر البرد وثم سيليها الحر في
في الصيف فالخيم هي
حل مؤقت يعني
لايام او لاسابيع وليس اكثر ماذا عن
الاغاثه فيما يتعلق بالاكل والشرب وغير
ذلك
نعم الاكل والشرب الحمد لله الان هو كافي
في المناطق التركيه ولكن هناك ضعف في
المناطق السوريه يعني في الشمال السوري
الشعب التركي الحمد لله
بكل اطيافه يعني ارسل
شيئا ما الى المناطق التركيه ولكن طبعا
هذه الحاجات يجب ان تكون يعني مستدامه
يعني الان نحن نتكلم عن اليوم غدا بعد غد
ولكن هذه الفتره سوف تطيل فيجب على الناس
ان لا يتوقفوا بارسال المساعدات الغذائيه
الان في هذه الايام هي كافيه في كل
المناطق التركيه
ولكن هناك نقص في الشمال السوري شكرا
جزيلا لك يا عبد الرحمن كوزم عضو مجلس
اداره منظمه خبيب التركيه للاغاثه
الانسانيه شكرا لك
حلب مراسل الجزيره عمرو حلبي عمر تابعناك
في اكثر من نشره هل من اضافات للوضع الذي
نقلته لنا اكثر من مره
محمد باختصار الاوضاع الانسانيه تزداد
سوءا الكارثه حجمها يكبر ويزداد ساعه بعد
ساعه يوما بعد اخر هنا شمال غربي سوريا
سواء في ريف حلب او حتى في ريف ادلب درجات
الحراره المعاناه حجمها يكون اكبر ما تكون
عليه خصوصا خلال الليل عندما تنخفض درجات
الحراره الى ما دون الصفر في بعض المناطق
من ريفي حلب وادلب انا الان واقف
في على احد الارصفه على قارعه الطريق
الرئيسي الواصل بين بلدات الريف حلب
شمال الغربي سوريا وهذا الرصيف اصبح مسكا
لمئات العائلات التي شردها الزلزال هذه
السياره مثلا التاكسي الصفراء يوجد
بداخلها طفلان وامراه وطلب منا ان لا
نتقدم اكثر اليها هي الان مسكا لاحدى
العائلات الصوره التي بعدها الخيمه هي بس
كان ايضا لعائله مشرده وهكذا على هذا
المنوال نحو اثنين الى ثلاثه كيلو متر
يوجد خيام على قارعه هذا الطريق فيه
عائلات مشرده الصوره الاخرى الان من هذا
الرصيف من هذا المكان الذي نحن فيه هذه
عائله امام خيمه هذه الخيمه يوجد بداخلها
عائله وامام الخيمه عائله لم تحظى بخيمه
وعلى امتداد هذا الرصيف كذلك تشاهد عائلات
تسكن على الرصيف تخيل محمد ان عائلات تنام
على هذا الرصيف في درجه حراره تحت الصفر
ليس عندهم سوى بطانيات وما يجلسون عليه
وهناك اطفال صغار وهناك نساء
والتحذيرات من احتماليه وفيات من هنالك
تحذيرات من مخاطر حدوث وحصول وفيات في
صفوف النساء والاطفال نتيجه درجات الحراره
المتدنيه ولانهم ينامون على الرصيف هذا
الرصيف يعني هم عوضه لكل شيء في الحقيقه
نحن هم لا يحدثوني تكلمت الى الكثير منهم
وسمعت قصص يشيب لها شعر الراس محمد لم
يحدثوني عن طعام لم يحدثوني عن ماء فقط عن
شيء
يقيهم شر البرد القارص خصوصا خلال درجات
المساء هذا الوضع الذي هو موجود هنا في
هذه المنطقه التي انا فيها يشبه في الوضع
في اماكن كثيره من البلدات والقرى
والمناطق التي ضربها الزلزال وتشردت
العائلات بسببها في جنديرس بريف حلب في
ريف ادلب كذلك وعموما نحن رصدنا الوضع في
اكثر من منطقه كذلك محمد هنا شمال الغربي
سوريا
شكرا لك عمرو حلبي من ريفه حلب
في هذه الاثناء افاده مراسل الجزيره بدخول
قافله مساعدات امميه جديده من معبر باب
الهوى مخصصه لمتضرري زلزال واضاف مراسلنا
ان القافله مكونه من 22 شاحنه وهي محمله
بمساعدات غذائيه وتضم بيوتا متنقله مخصصه
للسكن كما افاد مراسلنا بدخول وفد من
الامم المتحده من معمري معبر باب السلامه
الى مناطق سيطره المعارضه السوريه لتفقد
اضرار الزلزال في تلك المنطقه
هذا وقد قالت
المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه انه
طلب من الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد فتح
المزيد من نقاط العبور الحدوديه مع تركيا
وانه وافق على ذلك وحذر مدير منظمه الصحه
العالميه من ان الناجين من الزلزال في
سوريا يواجهون مناخا متجمدا دون ماوى
مناسب او تدفئه او طعام او مياه نظيفه او
رعايه طبيه
اما منظمه يوم المعنيه بحقوق الانسان
فوصفت الاستجابه الانسانيه للزلزال في
شمال غرب سوريا بانها كانت بطيئه وشددت
على الحاجه الماسه الى بدائل فعاله واضافت
المنظمه في بيان لها ان موافقه الحكومه
السوريه على معبرين حدوديين اضافيين الى
شمال غربي سوريا لثلاثه اشهر فقط ليست
خطوه متواضعه فحسب بل متاخره ايضا
اولا شكرا جزيلا على استضافتي هذا اليوم
وبالنيابه عن الولايات المتحده ووزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه نقول ان افكارنا
وتعازينا مع شعبان تركيا وسوريا في هذه
الاوقات
الكارثيه التي كلها تحديات منذ البدايه
كنا واضحين حول اهميه الاغاثه واهميه تدفق
الاغاثه الى سوريا وانه هو في غايه
الاهميه
وعندما كان معبرا حدوديا واحدا مفتوحا لم
يكن كافيا لضمان ان الاغاثه التي تضمن
انقاذ حياه الناس كان يتم بشكل طبيعي فتح
معابر اضافيه بالطبع عمر مرحب به لكن هذا
يجب ان يكون بشكل دائمي بحيث يكون تدفق
الاغاثه بشكل مستمر وما يتم وقفه وقطعه
لهذا السبب نحن نقول ان الولايات على
الامم المتحده ومجلس الامن ان يعملوا من
اجل هذه العمليه وماذا عن المساهمه
الامريكيه هل هي مرضيه في هذا المجهود
الدولي
هذه ليست من الامور التي تتوقف سوف تستمر
في تقييمنا
ولنجد افضل السبل لدعم شعب تركيا وشعب
سوريا منذ ساعات من هذه من وقوع هذا
الزلزال الكارثيه راينا الوقت المتحده وهي
تنشر فرق انقاذ وتبعث بدعم مالي لدعم جهود
الاغاثه ومستمرون في دعم الجهود على الارض
ونعمل ضمن نطاق توفير مساعدات ايواء
واطعام ودواء وايجاد السبل لدعم شعبي
سوريا وتركيا الذين تاثروا بهذا الزلزال
بالنسبه لتركيا الامور على ما يبدو تسير
بوتيره معقوله بالنسبه للشمال الغربي
لسوريا الناس يتذمرون ويشتكون
ما الحل لمعالجه هذا الاشكال بسرعه
الى العمل في الساعات
القليعه قبت هذا الزلزال وكنا واضحين منذ
البدايه ان النظام العقوبات الامريكي لا
يعوق تقديما مساعدات انسانيه في الحقيقه
كلما تعلق الامر بالمساعدات الانسانيه
اوضحنا هذه القضيه وفعلنا ذلك بعد زلزال
ونستمر في ذلك لضمان وصول الاغاثه الى
الذين يحتاجونها على ذكر المساعدات هل من
المنصف ان تصل اكثر من 60 طائره الى دمشق
حسب تصريح مسؤول سوري بوزاره النقل والا
يصل الى الشمال الغربي لاناس اصلا منكوبين
الا الشيء القليل
انا بالتاكيد لن اتحدث نيابه عن الحكومه
السوريه لكن هناك شيء كنا واضحين بشانه
منذ البدايه وهو اهميه تدفق المساعدات
بشكل حر ليصل الى الناس الذين يحتاجونها
قلنا دائما ان معبر حدودي واحد مفتوح لا
يكفي وهناك حاجه لفتح المزيد من المعابر
لتتدفق المساعدات بشكل حر وسوف نستمر
بالدفع بهذا الاتجاه عبر اليات الامم
المتحده وغيرها انتم دعوتم سواء النظام او
المعارضه الى عدم عرقله وصول المساعدات
والان هناك بعض نقاط الاستفهام تتعلق
بالشفافيه في وصول المساعدات التي تصل
الى النظام في دمشق وصولها الى جهات اخرى
ليست واقعه تحت سيطره النظام هل لديكم ما
تقولون في هذا الشان
المساعدات الاغاثيه الامريكيه تتم بطريقه
تضمن وصولها الى الشعب السوري الذي
يحتاجها وانها لا ترسل باتجاه نظام الاسد
نحن كنا واضحين تماما بشان ذلك هل انتم
واضحون ايضا فيما يتعلق بالموقف من الدول
التي سارعت بمناسبه الزلزال اما الى رفع
مستوى تمثيلها مع النظام في دمشق او الى
زياره دمشق لقاء الرئيس بشار الاسد هل من
موقف في هذا الموضوع
الان ليس وقت تسييس عمليات انقاذ
الانسانيه التي نحتاجها لانقاذ بحياه
الناس على كلا جانبي الحدود في تركيا
وسوريا كنا واضحين تماما بقدر ما يتعلق
الامر بالعلاقه بين نظام الاسد انهما لم
يتم هناك حل سياسي دائم يحفظ حق الشعب
السوري نحن لسنا مستعدين لتطبيع العلاقه
مع نظام بشار الاسد ولا نشجع اصدقائنا
وحلفائنا ليفعلوا ذلك هناك اليات لايصال
الاغاثه من دون ان تكون ذات منفعه لنظام
الاسد الولايات المتحده فعلت ذلك تماما
كان هذا اذا باتل النائب المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه في مقابله سجلناها قبل
الحصاد وخصصناها الى وصول المساعدات
بالخصوص الى الشمال الغربي السوري والموقف
من تسييس او عدم تسييس المساعدات الى
سوريا
تلقت مناطق منكوبه بالزلزال شمال غربي
سوريا شحنه اغاثه حملتها قافله من عشائر
في شرق سوريا ونقلت عشرات الشاحنات مواد
غذائيه وطبيبيه وخياما مراسلنا عمر
الحوراني رصد وصول حموله المساعدات الى
هناك
نرصد لكم على هذا الطريق الواصل بين ريف
حلب الشرقي ومدينه جنديرس الغربيه حلب
وصول عشرات الشاحنات المقدمه من العشائر
في دير الزور وذلك ضمن مبادره محليه تاتي
ضمن التكافل الاجتماعي لسد حاجه الاهالي
هنا في المنطقه جراء الزلزال وتاتي هذه
المبادره بعد النقص في تقديم المساعدات من
قبل الامم المتحده وهذه السيارات مستمره
بالوصول عبر هذا الطريق الواصل الى جنديرس
وتعتبر مدينه جنديرس من هي اكثر المناطق
تضررا هنا جراء الزلزال وتدمر فيها اكثر
من 85
% وايضا فيها الاف العائلات هي تشردت جراء
هذا الزلزال وايضا هي بحاجه الى تقديم
الاغذيه والايواء كما تحدث لنا مسؤولين في
هذه القافله ان تحتوي على خيام لكن يبقى
حاجه المنطقه هي حاجه اكبر من هذه
المساعدات وهي بحاجه الى مساهمه دول لسد
حاجه المتضررين الجراء هذا الزلزال
عمر الحوراني الجزيره
من منطقه جنديرس بريف حلب الشمالي سوريا
[موسيقى]
صدق الكنيسه الاسرائيليه بصوره النهائيه
على قانون يقضي بسحب الجنسيه والاقامه من
الاسرى الفلسطينيين من داخل الخط الاخضر
والقدس المحتله ممن تتهمهم اسرائيل بتنفيذ
عمليات ضد اسرائيليين وقد صوت لصالح
القانون اربعه وتسعون نائبا من الموالاه
والمعارضه في معارضه عشره وينص القانون
على الغاء الوضع القانوني لاسرى داخل
الفلسطيني والقدس وبعدهم فور انتهاء فتره
محكوميتهم الى مناطق السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه
اما وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه فوصفت قرار
كنيست بانه ابشع واشكال العنصريه وقال
بيان للخارجيه ان القراره جريمه تطهيرا
عرقي وتصعيد خطير يجر الاوضاع نحو
الانفجار الشامل واكدت الوزاره ان القانون
يطفي المزيد من المصداقيه على التوجه
الفلسطيني لتدوين القضيه الفلسطينيه
والتوجه الى مؤسسات الامم المتحده
والمحاكم الدوليه كما دانت حركه حماس قرار
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي ووصفته بالعنصريه
وقالت ان القانون يهدف الى ترحيل اسرى
القدس وفلسطين المحتله عام 1948 بذريعه
مقاومه الاحتلال وسياسته العنصريه واوضحت
الحركه ان الاجراءات الاسرائيليه تستوجب
تحركا دوليا وامميا لرفض ما وصفته بقوانين
الاحتلال العنصريه ومعاقبته على انتهاكاته
لمعايير حقوق الانسان
في هذه الورقه نتعرف اكثر على بعض
التفاصيل المهمه في قضيه الاسرى
الفلسطينيه وبالاخص الذين يستهدفهم
القانون الجديد الاسرائيلي
بعد اربعين عاما غدر كريم يونس المعتقل
الاسرائيلي بدات مرحله جديده من التوتر في
حياه كريم ومن بقي من ذويه بالاضافه الى
65 اسيرا اخرين من داخل الخط الاخضر
التوتر والقلق الجديد يتمثل في قرار
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي سحب الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه مما يحملها من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين قبل ان تتشكل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده كان الملف على طاوله
اطراف الائتلاف الحكومي الاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل اتفقت الاطراف على هذا
القانون الذي سيبعد بموجبه هؤلاء الاسرى
من مدنهم داخل الخط الاخضر الى مناطق
سيطره السلطه الفلسطينيه يضاف الى هؤلاء
الاسرى اكثر من 400 اسير من القدس المحتله
ستعاملهم اسرائيل وفق هذا القانون
تمت تفاصيل مهمه في فهم ما سيحدث يحمل
الفلسطينيون داخل فلسطين التاريخيه ثلاثه
انواع من الوثائق داخل الخط الاخضر يحملون
بطاقه هويه وجواز سفر اسرائيليين وهم في
هذه الحاله نظريا مواطنون اسرائيليون لهم
الحقوق وعليهم الواجبات لم يغادروا بيوتهم
ابانا النكبه ويبلغ عددهم الان مليون و600
الف فلسطيني تعتقل اسرائيل 65 منهم نفذوا
عمليات ضد الاحتلال واغلبهم حكم عليه
بالمؤبد معرضون الان لسحب الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه والطرد الى مناطق السلطه في
الضفه او غزه في القدس المحتله قرابه 100
الف فلسطيني الحديث هنا عن القدس التي
احتلتها اسرائيل عام 67 ولم تنسحب منها مع
اتفاق اوسلو هي القدس القديمه ومحيطها
يحمل الفلسطينيون هنا بطاقه اقامه مؤقته
في اسرائيل وج سفر اردنيا مؤقتا كذلك لان
الاردن هي صاحبه الوصايه على الاماكن
المقدسه وكانت تحكم هذه المنطقه هؤلاء
ليسوا مواطنين اسرائيليين ولا مواطنين
اردنيين ولا يحملون ما يثبت فلسطينتهم
بالوثائق معرضون الان لسحب هذه الاقامه
المؤقته والطرد كذلك الى مناطق الضفه او
غزه بجوار هؤلاء قرابه ثلاثه ملايين
فلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه ومليوناني في
قطاع غزه يحمل هؤلاء بطاقته هويه وجواز
سفر اصدرتهما السلطه الفلسطينيه عقب
انشائها عام 93 تعتقل اسرائيل اكثر من
اربعه الاف منهم وعندما يفرج عنهم يغادرون
الى بيوتهم او يبعد منتصفهم اسرائيل
بالخاطرين الى غزه او خارج البلاد بالعوده
الى ما بات يعرف بالمقدسيين وفلسطينيين
داخل تتحكم اسرائيل فيما يحملون من وثائق
بالاصدار والتمديد او الالغاء الحجه
الامنيه حاضره على الدواء هكذا تتبخر كل
الوثائق التي يحملها الفلسطينيون تحت سلطه
الاحتلال يحكم عليهم بقوانين تصدر لتحافظ
على الائتلافات الحكوميه وتطرفها وليس
بقوانين تصدر من دوله طبيعيه تتكون من ارض
وشعب
ومعنا من القدس احمد الطيبي رئيس كتله
ائتلاف الجبهه والعربيه للتغيير في
الكنيست الاسرائيليه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
طيبي ما اخطر ما في هذا القانون
انه يتعامل مع الانسان العربي
وهو الساكن الاصيل والمواطن الاصيل على ان
مواطنه مع وقف التنفيذ بينما يتعامل مع
اليهودي الذي جاء مؤخرا الى هذه البلاد
طبقا لقانون الهجره اليهودي بان المواطنه
هي دائمه وابديه هذه هي الفوقيه
اليهوديه الاسرائيليه وهذه العنصريه لانه
هناك يهود ارتكموا الجرائم ارهابيه اكثر
بكثير من الانضمام الى فصيل فلسطيني او ما
يسمى بتهمه الارهاب طبقا للقانون
الاسرائيلي وتلقي مخصصات اجتماعيه مثلا
قاتل اسحاق ربيع قاتل رئيس وزراء لم يفكر
احد مثل لم يطالب لم يفكر احد بسحب
مواطنطه او اقامته عمي الذي قام بمجزره
ذبح فيها سبع من
وغيرهم مبالغ ضجه لم يعني لم يخطر على بال
احد في المؤسسه معاقبتهم سحب الجنسيه او
الاقامه او عائلاتهم كما يفعلون اليوم
وما يميز القانون الذي طرح اليوم ونتيجه
التصويت عليه ان هذا القانون تم طرحه من
مبادرين من الحكومه الجديده
ومبادرين من الحكومه القديمه ولذلك
هذا الاجماع الصهيوني الكبير عليه ومن عرض
القانون هم فقط النواب العرب فقط نحن من
عرضنا القانون مع راي قضائي معارض لهذا
القانون للمستشاره القضائيه للحكومه خلال
المداولات في جلسه الكنيست هناك من يريد
ان يقول للفلسطيني في ارضه انت مؤقت
واليهودي حتى لو جاء من نيويورك قبل اسبوع
هو الدائم وهذا ما نرفضه
لا يوجد اي سبيل
عرض هذا القانون امام المحكمه العليا او
شيء من هذا القبيل هو نهائي وبات انا
متاكد انا متاكد انه سيتم عرضه امام الق
انون اخي محمد بعد الراي قانوني الذي
طرحته المستشار القضائيه للحكومه في
اللجنه البرلمانيه القانون لا يسري باثر
رجعي يعني الحكومه وسلطات الامن يجب ان
تثبت ان من يريد
قانون ان يسري عليه على هذا الشخص او ذاك
تسلم مخصصات اليوم من السلطه الفلسطينيه
وليس مخصصات في الماضي ولذلك
سيحاولون البحث
وتلفيق تهم لعدد من النشطات الفلسطينيين
وعدد من الفلسطينيين الذين تتهمهم اسرائيل
بتهمه الارهاب او الانضمام الى فصائل
فلسطينيه عندما ياتون الى فلسطين من اراضي
48 وتسحب جنسيته
ما وضعه بعد ذلك
على فكره لكي لا يكون سوء فهم بالماضي
سحبت جنسيا
فلسطينيين من ال 48 تم
طبقا للقانون السابق ليس للقانون الجديد
بتهمه الانضمام الى حزب الله
ولكن هذا القانون فيه تسهيل اخر قصه
المخصصات الماليه الاجتماعيه من قبل
السلطه والموقف الفاشل لهذه الحكومه يصبح
من تسحب منه المواطنه بلا مواطنه وبلا
اقامه مش بس المواطنه والاقامه ايضا ولذلك
القصد هو ابعاده الى اراضي السلطه الوطنيه
فلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه او في غزه طبقا
لما اعلنوها هؤلاء وفي هذا مخالفه للقانون
الاسرائيلي الذي يقول يمكن طرد اي مواطن
وسحب جنسيته اذا كانت لديه جنسيه اخرى
وطبعا كل الاسماء اللي مطروحه لتفعيل هذا
القانون لا يملكون جنسيات اخرى شكرا جزيلا
لك يا احمد الطيب رئيس كتله ائتلاف الجبهه
والعربيه للتغيير في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
كنت معنا من القدس
[موسيقى]
وغير بعيد عن اسرائيل اللي اكتشفها كشف
تحقيق استقصائيه يضم تسجيلات مصوره لمده 6
ساعات وشركت فيه اكثر من صحيفه اجنبيه كشف
الجرائم الالكترونيه التي تقوم بها مجموعه
الاسرائيليه اقرب الى مرتزقه حروب في
العالم الافتراضي ويذكر التحقيق استعانه
وكاله استخبارات وحملات انتخابيه وشركات
خاصه كذلك عبر العالم بهذه المجموعه
[موسيقى]
مافيا خرخيل اسرائيليه ليس عنوان فيلم
اثاره بل من اكثر العصابات القاتله
للحقيقه والمثيره للاضطرابات في العلمين
الافتراضي والحقيقي شعارها لا اخلاق ولا
تمييز مؤسسه الطاقم الاقرب الى مرتزقه
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الشقيقان قال
وزهار حنان عمل زهير سابقا في احد اجهزه
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه انضم اليه ملاحقا
ميشيميدان هو ايضا الرجل استخبارات سابق
متخصص في الحرب النفسيه وحملات التاثير
على الراي العام يستخدم كل من طال وزهار
اسما مستعارا هذه مقاطع من التحقيق
الاستقصائي الذي كشف عنهم وعن نشاطاتهم
المزعزعه للاستقرار على مدى عقدين من
الزمن تدخل طاقم خرقي باكثر من ثلاث عمليه
انتخابيه عبر العالم تلاعبوا بنتائجها
باستخدام القرصنه والتخريب ونشر المعلومات
المضلله عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يتباهى طال بعمليات القرصنه التي قام بها
فريقه امام ثلاثه صحفيين قدموا انفسهم على
انهم زبائن يريدون خدمات خرقي في دوله
افريقيه مضطربه يخبرهم بان قائمه زبائنه
تضم وكالات استخبارات وحملات انتخابيه
وشركات خاصه من جميع انحاء افريقيا
وامريكا الجنوبيه والوسطى والولايات
المتحده واوروبا اما عن الخدمات التي
توفرها المجموعه فنجد حزمه برامج متطوره
للتاثير الاعلامي وتعرف اختصارا
تتحكم في جيش ضخم من الاف الحسابات
الشخصيه الزائفه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مثل تويتر فيسبوك وتلجرام
وانستجرام ويوتيوب اضافه الى حسابات
الوهميه على مواقع امازون وار بي ام بي
مجهزه ببطاقه ائتمان ومحافظ بيتكوين خلال
ترويجه لبضاعته يذكر خرخي الهجمات
السيبرانيه التي تقدمها مجموعته يتحدث عن
هجوم ضد لجنه الانتخابات في اندونيسيا عام
2019 قبل شهر من الاقتراع استهدف ايضا
لاستفتاء الشعبي بشان استقلال اقليم
كتالونيا عن اسبانيا في 2014
بنشر انباء كاذبه في الصحافه الاسبانيه
تتحدث عن علاقه الحزب الكتالوني الانفصالي
بتنظيم داعش في الاعتراف المسجل دون علمه
تحدث رئيس المجموعه الالكترونيه عن
مشاركته في الترويج لاخبار لا اساس لها من
الصحه من اجل التاثير في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بفنزويلا عام 2012 بهدف منع فوز
الرئيس الراحل ايجو تشابس
اخطر ما كشفه التحقيق الذي شاركت فيه اكثر
من صحيفه اجنبيه مثل الجاردين
هو ان بعض عمليات التضليل اجريت من خلال
شركه
الاسرائيليه المسجله على موقع الكتروني
تديره وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه لتعزيز
الصادرات العسكريه
[موسيقى]
اثارت حمله اعتقالات نفذتها سلطات
التونسيه مؤخرا ضد ثمانيه شخصيات من بينها
سياسيين ونشطاء ومدير عام لاذاعه خاصه
اثارت جدلا بشان قانونيتها واسبابها وقال
الرئيس قيس سعيد ان هذه الايقافات تتعلق
بتهم التامر على امن الدوله بينما رات
جبهه الخلاص المعارضه الخطوه توجها واضحا
نحو الاستبداد داعيه للقوى السياسيه الى
التوحد بينما اعتبر الاتحاد والشغل حمله
الاعتقالات عشوائيه داعيا الى التعبئه
دفاعا عن الحريات في المواقف الدوليه عبرت
الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقها من التقارير
المتعلقه بهذه الاعتقالات وقالت انها تجري
اتصالات مع الحكومه التونسيه على كافه
المستويات دعما لحقوق الانسان وحريه
التعبير
اعتقالات شملت عددا من الشخصيات في تونس
لا شيء يربط بينها رغم تزامنها لكنها
اثارت جدلا واسعا في المشهد السياسي بسبب
ما وصفه محامو غالب الموقوفين بخلو
الملفات من اي تهم وقضايا واضحه المدير
العام لاذاعه موزاييك الخاصه احد
المشمولين بالايقاف قالت محاميته ان
الاسئله التي وجهت اليه في اثناء التحقيق
اقتصرت على مصادر تمويل الاذاعه وخطها
التحريري لم يختلف الامر مع رجل الاعمال
كمال الطيب والنشيطين السياسيين عبد
الحميد الجلاصي وخيام التركي والازهر
العكرمي وقت للانسان ما عنده شيء على
المتهمين سوى حقد عليهم لانهم معارضيه
وبالتالي حاول يشوههم بكل الوسائل وكل
التهم وفاق لتغيير هيئه الدوله بالقوه
وين الوفاق هذا اكد سمير ديلو محامي
القيادي بحركه النهضه نور الدين البحيري
انه اعتقل بسبب تصريح اعلامي تمديد من
المعارضه بحمله الاعتقالات التي نفذتها
السلطه ضد عدد من الشخصيات والرئيس قيس
سعيد يتعهد بمحاسبه من وصفهم بالمتامرين
على امن الدوله
يؤكد الرئيس قيس سعيد خلال حديثه مع عدد
من قيادي وزاره الداخليه انما وصفها بمهمه
انقاذ تونس من المتامرين والمجرمين
متواصله وان تهام الموقوفين تتعلق بالتامر
على امن الدوله وتهديد مستقبل شعبها لا
بالحقوق والحريات
هؤلاء الذين تم اعتقالهم ارهابيين
ولابد ايضا ان يحاسبوا بالقانون ولكن لم
نترك تونس لقمه
لهؤلاء المجرمين
الارهابيين الذين يريدون التنكير بالشعب
التونسي وفي حين بدت هذه الاعتقالات فصلا
جديدا من فصول الصراع بين الرئيس سعيد
ومعارضيها فانها ايضا تعمق من خلافه مع
اتحاد الشغل اكبر المنظمات النقابيه في
البلاد ميس الفتناص الجزيره تونس
الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذ وصف
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل الوضع في اوكرانيا
بالمقلق وقال ان عدد الجنود الروس حاليا
وضعف ما كان عليه قبل الحرب ياتي ذلك
بالتزامن مع اعلاني رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه عن حزمه عاشره من العقوبات ضد
موسكو تشمل مزيدا من القيود على التصدير
حاربهم بعقابهم ما زال الاوروبيون اوفياء
لنهج انتهى الى فرض تسع حزم عقوبات على
روسيا وثمت عاشره تقترحها المفوضيه
الاوروبيه مع اقتراب ذكرى السنويه الاولى
للحرب في اوكرانيا
اليوم نزيد الضغط بحزمه مكثفه من العقوبات
نقترح مزيدا من الحظر على التصدير بقيمه
تزيد عن 11 مليار يورو لحرمان الاقتصاد
الروسي من التكنولوجيا الحيويه والسلع
الصناعيه سنقيد بشكل اكبر تصدير السلع ذات
الاستخدام المزدوج والسلع التقنيه
المتقدمه لا يرى الروس في العقوبات
الغربيه سوى جزء مما يسمونها حربا هاجينه
معلنه عليهم لكن موسكو على قناعه كما يبدو
بان شيئا ما في العالم قد تغير
يقول وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان بلاله ستركز
في سياستها الخارجيه الجديده على انهاء ما
وصفه باحتكار الغرب لشؤون دوليه وصولا الى
عالم متعدد الاقطاب
لا يوضح ما اذا كانت الحرب مع اوكرانيا
مقدمه في الفهم الروسي لاعاده صياغه
التوازنات الدوليه
لكن قبل ذلك كله من الاقرب الى الحسم في
الميدان يبدو الوضع مقلقا للغايه باعتراف
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي فكيف كما ينبه جوسيب بوريل لا
تتمتع لاول مره باسبقيه في عدد الجنود على
الارض الا يحتم هذا الواقع على حلفاء
اوكرانيا الغربيين تنسيق دعم عسكري اكبر
للاوكرانيين
من انظمه الدفاع الجوي من قبل الشركاء
ومزيد من الدبابات والمدفعيه والقذائف
ومزيد من عمليات التدريب لجيشنا لا يمكن
الابلاغ عن كل شيء بشان رمشتاين علنا يجب
ترك جزء كبير من الاتفاقات خلف الابواب
المغلقه
لن تخفي تلك الابواب الانزعاج الاوكراني
من تاخر وصول ما جرى التعهد به من اسلحه
هجوميه نوعيه فالمانيا مثلا تقر بان هدفها
الخاص بتوفير كتيبتي مدرعات مزوده بدبابات
القتاليه لاوكرانيا لم يتحقق حتى الان
وبينما ضبط الناتو المواعيد النهائيه
لتوليد المعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيا
تتزايد مخاوف داخل الحلف من نفاد مخزونات
الاسلحه والذخيره في الدول الغربيه
المشكله الاكبر ان يتزامن ذلك مع توقع تلك
الدول استعداد الروس لجولات حرب جديده
ومعنا من فرانك
المحاضر الفلسطينيه العسكريه بجامعه
بورتسماوث وضبط السابق في المخابرات
العسكريه البريطانيه اهلا وسهلا بك هذه
المخاوف الغربيه من الوضع العسكري الحالي
في اوكرانيا هل هي مخاوف مشروعه
تعتقد انها فعلا مشروعه
فاوكرانيا تجد
الوقف الموقف في شرق البلاد كما سمعت منهم
موقف صعب جدا وكذلك يؤمنون بان الصمود
وهناك موضوع خاص
وهو في منطقه محمود التي محاطه الان من
ثلاثه جوانب والامريكان
ينصحون الاوكرانين بالانسحاب لكن
الاوكرانيين يرفضون ذلك ويقررون ويرون انه
البقاء لفظ البقاء وحتى لو تحملوا ضحايا
انه موقف صعب في مناطق اخرى الوضع بشكل
عام صعب لاوكرانيا حاليا هل تشعر بنوع من
الفطور في الموقف الغربي في دعم اوكرانيا
فلو نظرنا الى المسار نزلنا المسار هو في
اتجاه متصاعد بشكل مستمر واعتقد سيبقى
هكذا لعده اشهر لكن المشكله هي
خطيره مشكله هي هناك توقعات توقعات سمح
لها بالتفكير بها في حين ان الحقائق على
الارض اوافق مع هذه التوقعات فربما كانت
هناك توقعاتهم بقوات مدرعه كبيره ستصرف في
الربيع هذا امر لن يحصل لا يمكن ان يحصل
وفي الواقع يقول هو جوانب عمليه لابد
التغلب عليها قبل ذلك وبالتالي الامر
يتعلق بالتوقعات وواقع الحال ادى الى هذه
الصعوبات اشاره جوزيف بوريل الى ان عدد
الجنود الروس الان هو ضعف عدد الجنود
الروس قبل الحرب هل هل فيه اشاره الى ان
العنصر البشري الان مهم ربما اكثر من من
الاسلحه
تثير السؤال المهم جدا فعلا نعم العنصر
البشري
مهميه فيها نوعيه بذاتها ولكن اذا لم تحمي
كميه الجنود التي لديك اذا كانت قادم سيئه
وتدريبهم سيئه فان احتمال نجاحهم اقل
ويبدو هذه احدى مشاكل تعاني من روسيا في
منظمه في مجال اللوجستيك فعلا اعدادهم
زادت بشكل كبير كما ان مشاكل اوكرانيا هي
ايضا مشابهه رغم انها فعدد الضحايا
الاوكرانين مرتفع جدا
يجرون صعوبه في التعويض عن هؤلاء الضحايا
وهذه طبيعه في هذه الحرب اذا عنصر البشري
كاعداد مهم ولكن بالتاكيد ليس هو العنصر
الحاسم ما هو حاسم هي القياده والمعنويات
وثالثا المعدات ونوعيه المعدات على ذكر
المعدات تحديدا هل هناك اشكال في ان
الاوكرانيين
يستلمون اسلحه من امريكا من فرنسا من
بريطانيا من المانيا وبالتالي هناك اشكال
في دمج كل ذلك في منظومه عسكريه متناغمه
العنصر الاكثر صعوبه في المساعدات الغربيه
فهناك عده منصات وكل منصه فيها منظماتها
الاستحيه تعتمد على النوع الدبابه نوع
العجبه كل واحد من هذه الطله تدريبات
ولوجستيه وكل من عمل بالعسكريه يعرف ذلك
فمثلا الاوكرانيون
يشغلون لا اقل من 12 نوع من
المدفعيه المتحركه فيها انظمتها الكترونيه
خاصه لكل واحد منها
وعجلاته خاصه وحتى ان بعضها لديهم حتى
ذخائر مختلفه ليست مدفعيه فقط ليس فقط
الغربيه بل ايضا دبات والانظومات الصواريخ
و تشاهدون المشكله وبالتالي هذا التكامل
فعلا مهم جدا
ارى انه يفسدون صعوبه في فيه وبالتالي هذا
الموضوع مهم جدا لا شك في ذلك اطلاقا
شكرا جزيلا لك فرانك لاجود من اوكسفورد
[موسيقى]
راس ساعه وهذا تذكير بابرز العناوين
في اليوم العاشر على الزلزال في تركيا
اتساع رقعه المناطق المنكوبه بعد ضم ولايه
جديده الى القائمه وفرق الانقاذ تواصل
اخراج نجيب منظمه الصحه العالميه تحذر من
خطر تفشي الامراض المعديه وكاميرا الجزيره
ترافق عمليات ايصال المساعدات الى المناطق
النائيه
في سوريا حصيله ضحايا الزلزال تقترب من
سته الاف قتيل وعلى وقع معاناه ما بعد
الكارثه مطالبات مستمره بتسهيل دخول
المساعدات
تدعو الاعتماد اليه جديده لادخال
المساعدات الى الشمال السوري
وفي احدث تجليات سياسات اقصى اليمين
الاسرائيلي بحق الفلسطينيين الكنيسه يصدق
على ابعاد الاسرى المقدسيين وسحب الجنسيه
من المتهمين بتنفيذ عمليات والسلطه
الفلسطينيه تعتبر القرار جريمه تطهيرا
عرقي وتصعيدا خطيرا من شانه جر الوضع نحو
الانفجار وحركه حماس تدين القرار وتدعو
الى تحرك دولي ضد مواصفاتها بالقوانين
الاحتلاليه العنصريه
بعد اعتقالات طالت شخصيات سياسيه واعلاميه
المعرضه التونسيه تندد وتدعو القوه
السياسيه الى الوحده الاتحاد الشغل يدعو
الى التعبئه دفاعا عن الحريات والرئيس
السعيد يتهم المعتقلين بالتامر على امن
الدوله والخارجيه الامريكيه تعبر عن قلقها
وتؤكد اهميه وجود نظام قضائي مستقل وشفاف
لحمايه الحريات العامه
تستمر في تركيا اعمال ورفع الانقاض والبحث
عن ناجين وانتشار الجثث وترتفع معها حصيله
القتلى اذ بلغت في تركيا وحدها خمسه
قتيلا وفق احصاء كشفت عنه اداره الكوارث
والطوارات التركيه وادى الزلزال بحسب
المسؤولين الاتراك الى تهجير مليونين
ومئتي الف شخص بينما نصبت عشرات الالاف
القيام في المناطق المنكوبه لايواء مئات
الالاف الذين اصبحوا بلا ماوى هذا وقد
اصدر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
توجيهات باعتبار الالازيغ الولايه الحاديه
عشره منطقه منكوبه لتاثرها هي ايضا
بالزلزال
وبعد عشره ايام من الزلزال المدمر تتشبث
فرق الانقاذ بالامل في العثور على ناجين
وقد تكللت هذه الجهود بالنجاح في انطاكيا
والكهرمان مراش وهو ما دفع وزير الداخليه
التركي للحديث عن امال في العثور على
المزيد
لحظات ينتظرها الجميع بفارغ الصبر
رغم مرور عشره ايام على زلزال كهرمان مراش
تخرج فرق الانقاذ امراه وطفليها احياء في
مدينه انطاكيا بولايتها
وهذه امراه في كهرمان مراش مركز الزلزال
المدمر نجت ايضا بعد بقائها تحت الانقراض
222 ساعه وهذه المسنه ذات 77 عاما انقذت
بعد تسعه ايام من بقائها تحت انقاظ منزلها
في اليمن مشاهد يامل الجميع ان تكثر
وتتكرر بمرور الوقت لملاها من تاثير في
نفوس ذوي الضحايا وهمه ومعنوياتي فرق
الانقاذ
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخراج شخص اخر ما
زال على قيد الحياه من تحت الانقاض في
قهرمان مراش وما زال نعلق الامال على
الوصول الى مزيد من الناجين زملائنا في
الميدان يواصلون العمل بكل عزم واخلاص
امثله كثيره النجاه فيها اشخاص بعد مرور
الوقت المقدر فيه بقائهم احياء تحت
الانقاض ومنها رجل بقي حيا بعد 12 يوما
تحت الانقاض التي خلفها زلزالها ايتي عام
الثابت ان الامل باخراج احياء لا يخضع
لمنطق الارقام والقياس الى حالات سابقه
ولا ترضمه قتامه مشاهد الخراب فهو دائما
فسحه لا سقف لها ولا حدود
هذا وقد استيقظ الناجون من الزلزال في
تركيا على واقع توقف توقف فيه ايقاع
الحياه كما اعتادوها فكيف توفر السلطات
التركيه الطعامه لملايين المنكوبين جراء
الزلزال في ظل توقف شبهي كامل للمطاعب عن
تقديم الوجبات واغلاق متاجر المواد
الغذائيه التي تضررت كغيرها يونس ايه
ياسين نقل لنا كيف تساهم الجمعيات الخيريه
والمتطوعون في توفير الطعام للمنكوبين
مدينه غازي عنتاب بعد الزلزال محل موصده
ومطاعم مغلقه في مدينه كانت تنبض بالحياه
العاملون فيها تائهون بينما يحاول اجلاء
اسرته وبين من يبحث عن مكان يصلح للعيش
بعد توالي الهزات
محمد واحد من هؤلاء عاش رعب ليله الزلزال
مع اسرته تنقل بين الاقامه في المساجد
وصلات العزاء ثم استقر به المقام هنا مع
والدته واطفاله لم يفكر محمد في مشكله
اطعام اسرته فالمراكز التي اعدتها بلديه
غازي عنتاب بالتعاون مع المتطوعين وجمعيات
خيريه توزع يوميا ملايين الوجبات الساخنه
بالاضافه الى توزيع الطعام علينا يقوم
مجموعه من اهل الخير بتوزيع احتياجات
الاطفال كالحليب وغيره لكن هذا لا يمنع
وجود السلوكيات غير لائقه من البعض هنا
كالشرقه والاحتكار
جلوس كان المدينه والولايات العاشر
المتاثره بالزلزال كحال محمد باتوا
يعتمدون على الوجبات المجانيه
كان هذا المطعم يصنف قبل الزلزال بانه من
فئه خمس نجوم الان بامكاني سكان المدينه
غنيهم وفقيرهم تناول طعامه وبالمجان في
مظهر من مظاهر التكافل التي ظهرت بعد
الزلزال والتي خففت من معاناه الالاف
يشرف الشيف نوح على فريق من موظفي المطعم
والمتطوعين يحرص على معايير الجوده
المعتاده وكان شيئا لم يحدث
تصلهم المواد الاوليه من جمعيات خيريه ومن
البلديه فيعدون ويقدمون مئات الالاف من
الوجبات يوميا لمحتاجيها يقدم هذا المطعم
بفروعه ومطاعم اخرى في ولايه غازي عنتاب
ملايين الوجبات
نعمل على مدار اليوم ونوفر عبر فروعنا
ملايين الوجبات للمحتاجين
تظافر الجهود الحكوميه والخاصه ازاح عن
المتضررين من الزلزال اهم البحث عن الطعام
مؤقتا لكن الى متى بظل غياب افق زمني واضح
لموعد نهايه عيش المشردين في الشوارع
خصوصا في الولايات الاكثر تاثرا بالزلزال
وهو سؤال يطرحه سكان المخيمات
ياسين الجزيره
غازي عنتاب
معنى من اسطنبول مسؤول الشرق الاوسط بهيئه
الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد
فيما يتعلق بالاغاثه على مستوى الطعام
مثلما تابعنا كيف تسير الان في مختلف
نواحي تركيا
نعم اهلا مساء الخير لكم وللمشاهدين طبعا
كما نعرف ان المنطقه التي تضررت هي منطقه
واسعه مساحه كبيره جدا نتكلم عن الف كيلو
متر مربع
فلذلك تضررت كثير من القرى في المناطق
الجبليه وفي مناطق الاراء فلذلك المناطق
التي في المركز يوفر الاكلات او الاغذيه
بشكل اسهل من ان توصل هذه المساعدات الى
القرى كيف تكون الطريقه الايصال المساعدات
الوجبات الساخنه والاحتياجات الى تلك
القرى التي نتحدث عن
البرد القاسعه جدا في تلك المناطق تحت
الصفر عشرين درجه وفيها الثلوج كثيره فكيف
يتم الترتيبه اولا يصل المساعدات بشكل عام
الى مستودعات
بشاحنات الكبيره ومن ثم يتم تعبئته او يتم
ترتيبه في السياره الصغيره التي يمكن
الوصول الى تلك القرى لكن انضمت تكون
الثلوج كثير موجوده في الطرق يستخدم
السيارات الذي عندهم المحاريف للثلوج يفتح
الطرق لكي يصل السيارات التي هي معباه
بالاحتياجات
لتلك السكان الذي في القرى طبعا هذه
الطريقه الواحده فقط وفي طريقه الثانيه
نتكلم عن سيارات المركبات على طريق طرق
الوعيره يعني في متطوعين ياتي بسيارتهم
هذه المركبات على الطريق الوعره ويعبي من
الاحتياجات الوجبات الساخنه او حقيبه
الصحه او البطانيات وملابس مثل هذه الامور
يوصل بهذه المركبات الخاصه لتلك الطرق
ويوصل الى تلك القرى فيعني
الطرق الثالث الذي يمكن ان توصل لمساعدات
الواجبات الساخنه يطبخ الوجبات في اماكن
المركزيه الذي في المدينه كهرباء مرش
كمثال يطبخ في مطبخ الخيري الكبيره وثم
يعبا هذه الوجبات في السياره عربه التمويل
هذه العربات التموينيه هي مهم جدا لكن
يحتاج الى كثير من العربات لانه عربه
الواحده العرب التموين الواحده تستطيع ان
تصل فقط الى القرى او قريتين في يوم واحد
لانه لابد ان يمشي الصباح
وفي الغداء وفي العشاء يوصل ثلاث مرات في
اليوم ويوزع يستطيع يوزع 1000 وجبات ساخنه
في في خلال الوجبه الغداء والعشاء فلذلك
يعني القرى التي هي متاثره في التلك
المناطق كثيره
ولذلك يحتاج مثل هذه السيارات العربه
التموين بكثره وزياده لكي توصل هذه
المساعدات الى تلك القرى وتلك المناطق
يعني هذه طبعا بسبب البرد القارس يصعب
الامر
يعني اكثر مما في مدينه
المراكز المدينه يعني شكرا جزيلا لك ومت
بالجن مسؤول للشرق الاوسط بهايه الاغاثه
الانسانيه التركيه كنت معنا من اسطنبول
واستمرار لنفس الحديث عن المناطق النائيه
رصدا مراسل شبكه الجزيره اليه ايصال
المساعدات من قبل القوات التركيه الى
المناطق النائيه بولايه اضنه التي ضربها
الزلزال
مروحيه تابعه للقوات التركيه تحاول ايصال
المساعدات الى المناطق النائيه التي ضربها
الزلزال يمكن من النافذه معاينه التضاريس
الصعبه لهذه المنطقه اي احد سيعاني في
محاوله الوصول الى هذه المناطق
بيبال شاهقه مكسوه بالثلوج لذا فالوصول
الى هنا مهمه صعبه فما بالكم بهذه الكميه
من المساعدات الناس في المناطق المحيطه
طالبوا في الايام الماضيه على منصه
التواصل بارسال مساعدات الى هذه المنطقه
من قوه التركيه تعمل جاهده لايصال
المساعدات الى هؤلاء الناس المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال تبلغ مساحتها مساحه دوله
كامله وعدد المتضررين هنا يتجاوز عدد سكان
الدوله كامله كذلك هذه معاناه لكل من يريد
المساعده هذه قريه اخرى ضربها الزلزال
سكانها يناشدون للمساعده في هذه المروحيه
مساعدات متنوعه من ملابس واغذيه بالنسبه
لهؤلاء الجنود هذه ليست مجردا مهمه عسكريه
هذه عائلاتهم التي تحتاج الى مساعده لذلك
كثير من التوتر والعمل تحت الضغط النفسي
الهائل بالنسبه لهؤلاء الجنود
هذا في تركيا اما في سوريا فقد ارتفعت
اعداد القتلى جراء الزلزال الى خمسه الاف
وثمانمائه قتيل في عموم البلاد الى جانب
الاف المصابين وقال الدفاع المدني في شمال
سوريا ان فرقه تواصل عمليات البحث تحت
الالقاب بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب شمال غربي
سوريا واوضح الدفاع المدني في تغريد على
تويتر انه يعمل على فتح الطرقات المغلقه
وكشف ان فرقه وثقت انهيار اكثر من 500
مبنا وتضررا وتضرر اكثر من
1570 مبنى بشكل جزئي
هذا وتبيت مئات العائلات التي دمر الزلزال
بيوتها شمال غربي سوريا تبيت في العراء
دون خيام او ماوى مراسل عامر حلبي قد ليلى
مع العائلات النازحه التي تفترش الطرقات
قرب جندريس جنديرس عفوا التي دمر الزلزال
85 من مبانيها بريف حلب
[موسيقى]
لا ينقطع بكاء هذا الطفل الصغير
لا يعرف من الشكوى سوى مناداه والدته
اما الاخرون الذين دمر الزلزال بيوتهم
وشردهم الى العراق فيعرفون كيف يوصلون
شكواهم لكنهم لا يعرفون ان كان ثمه من
يستجيب لهم
بعضهم حدثونا واخرون لم يستطيعوا الكلام
خلاص الله يعطيك العافيه
على الله
رب العالمين
اما من تكلم فحدثنا عن فظاعه ما مر به
ومعايشه
بدي احكي
سبعه ايام اليوم صارنا على الارض سبعه
ايام مرضى عند الولاد مرضانين
يعني الوضع اسرع من هيك يمكن مستحيل ما
يعني شايفين يعني شي قبال عيونكم ذبحنا
البرد والله العظيم مثل البرد والجوع
ومرضانه وانا مره يعني معاي سكرين
احد عشر الف عائلتي سوريا
بعضها حظيه بخيمه او مكان في مركز ايواء
لكن كثيرين منهم باتوا في العراق
هنا ينامون وياكلون ان وصلهم شيء من الخبز
والطعام
مره اكثر من اسبوع على الزلزال لكن ارتجاف
اجسادهم كل ليله لا يقل الما عن اليوم
الذي دمرت فيه بيوتهم
قد لا تكون المعاناه جديده على حياتهم
لكنها من اكبر الماسي التي حلت بهم
ذو الحراره تحت الصفر لا ماوى ولا دفئ سوى
هذه النار
قضينا ساعات مع هذه العائلات النازحه التي
شردها الزلزال انهم هنا منذ سبعه ايام في
العراء والمعاناه ينتظرون الغوث ويسالون
هل من مجيب عمرو حلبي الجزيره من محيط
جنديرس ريف حلب
ومعنا من ادلب عبد الرزاق عوض مدير منظمه
سيريا ريليف اهلا وسهلا بك
كيف تتعاملون على مع حالات من هذا القبيله
الذي التي تبعناها في هذا التقرير
مساء الخير لكم في الحقيقه يعني نحن لا
نتعامل مع هذه الحالات نحن نعيش هذه
الحالات يوميا سرقنا الميدانيه كل يوم
ونحن كل يوم نعايش هذه الحالات يعني
اغلب نهارنا معهم
نحاول ما استطعنا ان نقدم لهم لكن
يعني انت لاحظت ان اغلب يعني اقصى احلامهم
هو خيمه الان
يعني انا تكلمت اكثر من مره عبر منبركم عن
نقص المواد الشديد في الشمال السوري اليوم
وخصوصا الخيام يعني نحن وصلنا العديد من
التبرعات الفرديه لكن يعني نواجه نقص حاد
في الخيام نريد ان نشتري خيام لكنه نواجه
نقص حاد في هذه المواد نقدم لهم الفرس
نقدم لهم البطانيات نقدم لهم الوجبات
يوميا لكن نواجه صعوبه كبيره في تامين
الخيام اليوم وبعد يعني عشره ايام تقريبا
من الكارثه اليوم اخبرت ان انه دخلت من مع
باب الهوى لاول مره
قافله للامم المتحده تحمل الخيام عسى ان
تنتهي هذه المشكله غدا او بعد غد بعد
توزيع هذه الخيام عليهم يعني هل لديكم عدد
تقريبي لعدد الخيام التي تحتاجونها هناك
في منطقه جنديرس استاذ محمد لدينا اكثر من
500 عائله اكثر من 500 عائله بالضبط بحاجه
الى خيام نحن يعني لم نستطع بعد مراكز
لواء الجماعيه كما تحدث عمر في تقريره
وبعد الخيام التي شاهدتموها في التقرير
التي تؤوي كل خيمه يمكن عائلتين او ثلاثه
لم نستطع تامين هذه الخيام لهم
اعتقد ان ما دخل اليوم سيكون كافي لاواء
العوائل في خيام لكل ممكن ان يعني ان شاء
الله ان يكون لكل عائله خيمه وممكن ان
نحتاج الى عدد ايضا من الخيام في مرحله
لاحقه وماذا بالنسبه للاعاشه هل هل تبدو
ايسر قليلا
كل يوم نحن نعتمد بصراحه في المرحله هذه
على الاستجابه اليوميه الطارئه يعني نحن
من يعني نحن نقدم الوجبات نحن نقدم السلال
الجاهزه للاكل بشكل فوري
مرحله الاعاشه الدائمه سنفكر فيها في
مرحله لاحقه عندما تنوي هذه العائلات
ويعني ننتهي من حاله
بيت يعني العائلات في العراء مبيت
العائلات في العراء سنفكر في مرحله لاحقه
ان شاء الله ان يكون لهم ان يوزع عليهم
مبالغ شهريه تكفيهم طيله طيله الشهر لكن
هذه ستكون مرحله يعني في مرحله قادمه
اعتقد ليس اقل من عشره ايام الى الى 15
يوما هل وصلتكم ايه مساعدات من مناطق اخرى
من سوريا اقصد المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
النظام
لا لم يصلنا من النظام عبر خطوط التماس اي
قافله مساعدات وصلنا من
يعني من اهلنا السوريين في مدينه دير
الزور اصبح معلوما يعني لكل وسائل الاعلام
وصلنا قافله كبيره
يعني هذه
نعتبرها يعني اغاثه السوريين لبعضهم البعض
وللعلم القافله التي دخلت من اهلنا في دير
الزور اكبر بكثير
واعددها اكبر بكثير من كل القوافل التي
دخلت للامم المتحده حتى الان هل لديكم اي
تصور عن القوافل التي يفترض ان تاتي في
الايام المقبله وبالتالي تستطيعون جدولتها
بشكل واضح
في الحقيقه اجتمعنا مع الوفد الامم
البارحه اجتمعنا مع المبعوث الاموي الذي
دخل الى منطقه ادلب جلست معه لساعات
ابلغناه اسفنا ابلغنا اعتذاره المكرر على
وسائل الاعلام
واخبرناه اننا بحاجه لان نعرف حقيقه ما هو
توجههم ما هي خطتهم ماذا ينمون ان يقدمون
لحتى نعرف انه جدول خططنا على هذا الاساس
وعدنا يعني نحن وزملائنا في المنظمات
الاخرى بتقديم ما يكفي من الدعم لم يحدد
ارقام لم يحدد مواعيد
اخبرنا اخبرونا انهم سيعملون على ذلك دون
اي جدوله لاي مواعيد واي ارقام او اعداد
اخبرونا انهم سيقومون بما يلزم فقط هل هذا
يمكن ان يخفف ولو نسبيا خيبه الامل
المريره التي كانت لدى السوريين في شمال
غرب البلاد
ما يخفف يعني الم السوريين وخيبات املهم
في الامم المتحده هو تحييد الملف الانساني
السوري لهؤلاء الناس عن اي عن اي اجندات
سياسيه نحن اول من ينادي بذلك لا ان ننتظر
يعني
موافقه من شرد هؤلاء السوريين في الزلزال
المدمر لسوريا منذ عشر سنوات الى الان
ننتظر موافقته لكي يفتح معبر الراعي ومعبر
باب السلامه اصلا خارج سيطرته هذا ما
يريده السوريون ان يعني ان تدخل المساعدات
دون اي قيد او شرط
الاعتذار مقبول لكن هذا الاعتذار يجب ان
يترجم الى حقيقه والى عمل يترجم على ارض
الواقع يخفف من معاناتهم وينتشلهم من هذه
الكارثه التي يعيشون فيها كل يوم شكرا
جزيلا لك السيد عبد الرزاق عوض مدير منظمه
السيره الرغيف من ادلب
وكان مراسلنا قد افاد بدخول قافله مساعدات
امميه جديده من معبر باب الهوى مخصصه
لمتضرري زلزال واضاف مراسلنا ان القافله
مكونه من اثنتين وعشرين شاحنه وهي محمله
بمساعدات غذائيه وتضم بيوتا متنقله مخصصه
للسكن كما افاد مراسل الجزيره بدخول وفد
من الامم المتحده من معبر باب السلامه الى
مناطق سيطره المعارضه السوريه لتفقد اضرار
الزلزال في المنطقه
وقد قالت دروس ادهنهم المدير العام لمنظمه
الصحه العالميه انه طلب من الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد فتح المزيد من نقاط العبور
الحدوديه مع تركيا وانه وافق على ذلك وحذر
مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه من ان الناجين
من الزلزال في سوريا يواجهون مناخا متجمدا
دون ماوى مناسب او تدفئه او طعام او مياه
نظيفه او رعايه طبيه اما منظمه هيوما
المعنيه بحقوق الانسان ووصفت الاستجابه
الانسانيه للزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا
بانها كانت بطيئه مشدده على الحاجه الماسه
الى بدائل فعاله واضافت المنظمه في بيان
لها ان موافقه الحكومه السوريه على معبرين
حدوديين اضافيين في شمال الى شمال غربي
سوريا لثلاثه اشهر فقط ليست خطوه متواضعه
فحسب بل هي متاخره ايضا
هذا وتشكل النساء والفتيات نحو 50% من اي
فئات لاجئه او ناجحه مع انه لا توجد
احصائيه حتى اللحظه عن عدد متضررين زلزال
تركيا وسوريا من النساء بشكل خاص لكن
الكارثه كشفت عن حجم معاناتهن هذا التقرير
وصلت الضوء على جزء من قصصهم
[موسيقى]
تحدق دعاء الغضبان في صور زوجها واطفالها
الثلاثه وكانها لا تريد ان تصدق حول
الفاجعه لقد قتلوا جميعا فقد الدعاء
عائلتها الصغيره هنا في جمال سوريا بفعل
الزلزال ولم يتبقى لها سوى حزن يبدو انه
لن ينضب طلع لي اخي
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش
نادي اخواته
راح ادوس صلاه الفجر قالوا مات
لعائشه قصه اخرى مع حفيدتها الصغيره تمشي
قرب منزلها المدمر في بلده الاتارب بريف
حلب حيث تعيش في ماوى للطوارئ بعد ان
شردها الزلزال حرمتها الكارثه من الوصول
الى الخدمات الطبيه لعلاج امراض الكبد الم
الوحيد اللي لا صار تحت الانقاذ هلا بهذا
الزلزال يعني ربما شب ربما اب ربما جد عم
بيقول العيله ارامل واولاد صار تحت
الانقاض ضعف الزلزاله من ماساه عائشه
وكثير من النساء شمال البلاد وهن اصلا من
الفئات الاشد ضعفا كثير منهن ارامل وكثير
منهن نازحات في الاصل منذ سنوات طويله
تتواصل الاحزان الى الجوار التركي هنا في
الريحانيه بولات هاتاي نسوه يشاركنا دعاء
وعائشه مصيبه نفسها والفقد نفسه
لا ندري هلبكينا ازواجن اطفالهن ابائهن ام
شقيقتهم لكنها بالتاكيد جثث احبه
بعضهن فقدنا عائلاتهن ولم يتبقى لهن سوى
طفل او زوج وبعضهن لم يبقى لهن سوى الالم
في ماساه لا يعرف بعد كم عدد الضحايا
النساء فيها او من ترملنا او من اصبحنا
بلا حتى معيل
[موسيقى]
صدق الكنيسه الاسرائيليه بصوره نهائيه على
قانون يقضي بسحب الجنسيه والاقامه من
الاسرى الفلسطينيين من داخل الخط الاخضر
والقدس المحتله ممن تتهمهم اسرائيل بتنفيذ
عمليات ضد اسرائيليين وقد صوت لصالح
القانون اربعه وتسعون نائبا من الموالاه
والمعارضه في معارضه عشره وينص القانون
على الغاء الوضع القانوني لاسرى داخل
الفلسطيني والقدس وابعادهم فور انتهاء
فتره محكوميتهم الى مناطق السلطه
الفلسطينيه
هذا وقد وصفت وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
قرار الكنيست بانه ابشع اشكال العنصريه
وقال بيان خارجيه ان القراره جريمه تطهيرا
عرقي وتصعيد خطير يجر الاوضاع نحو
الانفجار الشامل واكدت الوزاره ان القانون
يطفي المزيد من المصداقيه على التوجه
الفلسطيني لتدوير القضيه الفلسطينيه
والتوجه الى مؤسسات الامم المتحده
والمحاكم الدوليه
وقد دانت حركه حماس قرار الكنيسه
الاسرائيليين ووصفته بالعنصري وقالت ان
القانون يهدف الى ترحيل اسرى القدس
وفلسطين المحتله عام 1948 بذريعه مقاومه
الاحتلال وسياسته العنصريه واوضحت الحركه
ان الاجراءات الاسرائيليه تستوجب تحركا
دوليا واماميا لرفض ما وصفته بقوانين
الاحتلال العنصريه ومعاقبته على انتهاكاته
بمعايير حقوق الانسان
بعد اربعين عاما غدر كريم يونس المعتقل
الاسرائيلي بدات مرحله جديده من التوتر في
حياه كريم ومن بقي من ذويه بالاضافه الى
65 اسيرا اخرين من داخل الخط الاخضر
التوتر والقلق الجديد يتمثل في قرار
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي سحب الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه مما يحملها من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين قبل ان تتشكل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده كان الملف على طاوله
اطراف الائتلاف الحكومي الاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل اتفقت الاطراف على هذا
القانون الذي سيبعد بموجبه هؤلاء الاسرى
من مدنهم داخل الخط الاخضر الى مناطق
سيطره السلطه الفلسطينيه يضاف الى هؤلاء
الاسرى اكثر من 400 اسير من القدس المحتله
ستعاملهم اسرائيل وفق هذا القانون
تمت تفاصيل مهمه في فهم ما سيحدث يحمل
الفلسطينيون داخل فلسطين التاريخيه ثلاثه
انواع من الوثائق داخل الخط الاخضر يحملون
بطاقه هويه وجواز سفر اسرائيليين وهم في
هذه الحاله نظريا مواطنون اسرائيليون لهم
الحقوق وعليهم الواجبات لم يغادروا بيوتهم
ابانا النكبه ويبلغ عددهم الان مليون و600
الف فلسطيني تعتقل اسرائيل 65 منهم نفذوا
عمليات ضد الاحتلال واغلبهم حكم عليه
بالمؤبد معرضون الان لسحب الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه والطرد الى مناطق السلطه في
الضفه او غزه في القدس المحتله قرابه 100
الف فلسطيني الحديث هنا عن القدس التي
احتلتها اسرائيل عام 67 ولم تنسحب منها مع
اتفاق اوسلو هي القدس القديمه ومحيطها
يحمل الفلسطينيون هنا بطاقه اقامه مؤقته
في اسرائيل وج سفر اردنيا مؤقتا كذلك لان
الاردن هي صاحبه الوصايه على الاماكن
المقدسه وكانت تحكم هذه المنطقه هؤلاء
ليسوا مواطنين اسرائيليين ولا مواطنين
اردنيين ولا يحملون ما يثبت فلسطينتهم
بالوثائق معرضون الان لسحب هذه الاقامه
المؤقته والطرد كذلك الى مناطق الضفه او
غزه بجوار هؤلاء قرابه ثلاثه ملايين
فلسطيني في الضفه الغربيه ومليوناني في
قطاع غزه يحمل هؤلاء بطاقته هويه وجواز
سفر اصدرتهما السلطه الفلسطينيه عقب
انشائها عام 93 تعتقل اسرائيل اكثر من
4000 منهم وعندما يفرج عنهم يغادرون الى
بيوتهم او يبعد منتصفهم اسرائيل بالخاطرين
الى غزه او خارج البلاد بالعوده الى ما
بات يعرف بالمقدسيين وفلسطينيين داخل
تتحكم اسرائيل فيما يحملون من وثائق
بالاصدار والتمديد او الالغاء الحجه
الامنيه حاضره على الدواء هكذا تتبخر كل
الوثائق التي يحملها الفلسطينيون تحت سلطه
الاحتلال يحكم عليهم بقوانين تصدر لتحافظ
على الائتلافات الحكوميه وتطرفها وليس
بقوانين تصدر من دوله طبيعيه تتكون من ارض
وشعب
وغير بعيدا عن اسرائيل كشف تحقيق استقصائي
يضم تسجيلات المصوره لمده 6 ساعات وشركت
فيه اكثر من صحيفه اجنبيه كشف الجرائب
الالكترونيه التي تقوم بها مجموعه
اسرائيليه هي اقرب الى مرتزقه حروب في
العالم الافتراضي ويذكر التحقيق استعانه
وكالات استخبارات وحملات انتخابيه وشركات
خاصه عبر العالم بهذه المجموعه
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
مافيا خرخيل اسرائيليه ليس عنوان فيلم
اثاره بل من اكثر العصابات القاتله
للحقيقه والمثيره للاضطرابات في العلمين
الافتراضي الحقيقي شعارها لا اخلاق ولا
تمييز مؤسسه الطاقم الاقرب الى مرتزقه
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الشقيقان قال
وزهار حنان عمل زهير سابقا في احد اجهزه
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه انضم اليه ملاحقا
ميشيميدان هو ايضا الرجل استخبارات سابق
متخصص في الحرب النفسيه وحملات التاثير
على الراي العام يستخدم كل من طال وزهار
اسما مستعارا هذه مقاطع من التحقيق
الاستقصائي الذي كشف عنهم وعن نشاطاتهم
المزعزعه للاستقرار على مدى عقدين من
الزمن تدخل طاق باكثر من ثلاثين عمليه
انتخابيه عبر العالم تلاعبوا بنتائجها
باستخدام القرصنه والتخريب ونشر المعلومات
المضلله عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يتباهى طال بعمليات القرصنه التي قام بها
فريقه امام ثلاثه صحفيين قدموا انفسهم على
انهم زبائن يريدون خدمات خرقي في دوله
افريقيه مضطربه يخبرهم بان قائمه زبائنه
تضم وكالات استخبارات وحملات انتخابيه
وشركات خاصه من جميع انحاء افريقيا
وامريكا الجنوبيه والوسطى والولايات
المتحده واوروبا اما عن الخدمات التي
توفرها المجموعه فنجد حزمه برامج متطوره
للتاثير الاعلامي وتعرف اختصارا
تتحكم في جيش ضخم من الاف الحسابات
الشخصيه الزائفه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مثل تويتر فيسبوك وتليجرام
وانستجرام ويوتيوب اضافه الى حسابات وهميه
على مواقع امازون
بمجهزه ببطاقه ائتمان ومحافظ بيتكوين خلال
ترويجه لبضاعته يذكر خرخي الهجمات
السيبرانيه التي تقدمها مجموعته يتحدث عن
هجوم ضد لجنه الانتخابات في اندونيسيا عام
2019 قبل شهر من الاقتراع استهدف ايضا
لاستفتاء الشعبي بشان استقلال اقليم
كتالونيا عن اسبانيا في 2014
بنشر انباء كاذبه في الصحافه الاسبانيه
تتحدث عن علاقه الحزب الكتالوني الانفصالي
بتنظيم داعش في الاعتراف المسجل دون علمه
تحدث رئيس المجموعه الالكترونيه عن
مشاركته في الترويج لاخبار لا اساس لها من
الصحه من اجل التاثير في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بفنزويلا عام 2012 بهدف منع فوز
الرئيس الراحل
اخطر ما كشفه التحقيق الذي شاركت فيه اكثر
من صحيفه اجنبيه مثل الجارديان ولوموند
وهارت والبيس ودير شبيجل هو ان بعض عمليات
التضليل اجريت من خلال شركه
الاسرائيليه المسجله على موقع الكتروني
تديره وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه لتعزيز
الصادرات العسكريه
ومعنا من واشنطن ستيفاني
المحرره في محرره التحقيقات في صحيفه
الجاردن واحدى محدده تحقيق الجارد اهلا
وسهلا بك سيدتي
ما اخطر ما في هذا التحقيق عن هذه
المجموعه
الجانب الاكثر خطوره هو حقيقه انهم تصرفوا
في الظل وخفيه
ومقصده بذلك هو انهم لا يتركون ايه اثار
او بصمات اصابع كما يقال الفريق
وطال حنان
والزملائه
حاولوا التدخل في انتخابات او التاثير في
نتائج بعض الاحداث كان من الصعب تماما
التاكد ممن قام مما قاموا به ولصالح من
فعلوا ذلك فلهم ولديهم قدرات تقنيه كثيره
جدا هذا ما كشفه تحقيقنا لديهم قدرات
قرصنه على وجه الخصوص لديهم ايضا قدرات
استخدام
ما يسمى الذباب الالكتروني
للتاثير في السرديات السياسيه عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي مثل الفيسبوك وتويتر
راينا ايضا فاعلين من الدول
تحاول التاثير في حملاتي وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لكن هذه المره هذه المساله
مختلفه لان اي طرف لديه المال يمكن ان
يستاجر خدمات فريق خورخيل ليفعل فعله من
دون ترك ايه اثار تدل عليهم ولكن ليس
غريبا ان هذه المجموعه تعمل لعشرين عاما
تقريبا دون ان تفضح
لهذا السبب شعر زملائي باهميه القيام
بعمليه تحقيق
استقصائيه سريه
للتوصل الى كنهي حكايتهم وما يقومون به
لانهم استطاعوا تجنب الاضواء وعندما
نستطيع كشفهم وتسليص الضوء عليهم سنفضحوا
اعمالهم ونشاطاتهم
ونعرف اين كانت هذه المجموعه تنشط ومن
الادله التي حصلنا عليها في افريقيا
وفي انتخابات كينيا وفي انتخابات سابقه في
نيجيريا كانت نقاط التركيز الرئيسيه التي
ركزنا عليها هل كان لهم اي دور في دول
عربيه دول شرق اوسطيه
باننا نعتقد
حنان كان نشطا في انحاء كثيره من العالم
وقد استطعنا من تحديد خارطه نشاطاته بشكل
دقيق لهذا السبب نحن لا نستثني اي بلد
منها
بعد هذا التحقيق هل تتوقعون تاثيرا ما على
هذه المجموعه تحاول ان تختفي او تحاول ان
تفعل اي رده فعل ممكنه
نعم سؤال وجيه للغايه حقيقه انا كنت
اتساءل هل ستكون هناك تحقيقات من جانب
اجهزه الشرطه حتى الان لم نرى ذلك يحدث
على الفور
وننتظر لنرى هل ستكون هناك ايه خطوات يتم
اتخاذها راينا من قبل اخبارا عن قرصنه بعض
الشخصيات السياسيه والتي في كينيا مثلا
تصدرت هذه الاخبار الصفحات الاولى للصحف
منذ ان علم الناس بالنشاط هذه المجموعه
نحن نتوقع ان يكون هناك المزيد من
التحقيقات والتطورات هذا لا يحدث عاده بين
عشيه وضحاها شكرا لك سيدي ستيفاني
ونذكر مره اخرى بانك محرره التحقيقات في
صحيفه الجارديان وانت احدى محرري تحقيق
الجاردين حول هذه الفضيحه
[موسيقى]
في تونس اثارت حمله اعتقالات النفاذات
السلطات مؤخرا ضد ثماني شخصيات من بينهم
سياسيين ونشطاء ومدير عام لاذاعه خاصه
اثارت جدلا بشان قانونيتها واسبابها وقال
الرئيس قيس سعيد ان هذه اللقافات تتعلق
بتهم التامر على امن الدوله بينما رات
جبهه الخلاص المعارضه الخطوه توجها واضحا
نحو الاستبداد ودعت القوى السياسيه للوحده
بينما اعتبر اتحاد الشغل حمله الاعتقالات
عشوائيه داعيا الى التعبئه دفاعا عن
الحريات وفي المواقف الدوليه عبرت
الخارجيه الامريكيه عن قلقها من التقارير
المتعلقه بالاعتقالات وقالت انها تجري
اتصالات مع الحكومه التونسيه على كافه
المستويات دعما لحقوق الانسان ولحريه
التعبير
سلسله اعتقالات شملت عددا من الشخصيات في
تونس لا شيء يربط بينها رغم تزامنها لكنها
اثارت جدلا واسعا في المشهد السياسي بسبب
ما وصفه محامو غالب الموقوفين بخلو
الملفات من اي تهم وقضايا واضحه المدير
العام لاذاعه موزاييك الخاصه احد
المشمولين بالايقاف قالت محاميته ان
الاسئله التي وجهت اليه في اثناء التحقيق
اقتصرت على مصادر تمويل الاذاعه وخطها
التحريري لم يختلف الامر مع رجل الاعمال
كمال الطيف والناشطين السياسيين عبد
الحميد الجلاصي وخيام التركي والازهر
العكرمي وقت للانسان ما عنده شيء على
المتهمين سوى حقد عليهم لانهم معارضين
وبالتالي حاول يشوههم بكل الوسائل وكل
التهم وفاق لتغيير هيئه الدوله بالق وه
وين الوفاق هذا اكد سمير ديلو محامي
القيادي بحركه النهضه نور الدين البحيري
انه اعتقل بسبب تصريح اعلامي تمديد من
المعارضه بحمله الاعتقالات التي نفذتها
السلطه ضد عدد من الشخصيات والرئيس قيس
سعيد يتعهد بمحاسبه من وصفهم بالمتامرين
على امن الدوله
يؤكد الرئيس قيس سعيد خلال حديثه مع عدد
من قيادي وزاره الداخليه انما وصفها بمهمه
انقاذ تونس من المتامرين والمجرمين
متواصله وان تهام الموقوفين تتعلق بالتامر
على امن الدوله وتهديد مستقبل شعبها لا
بالحقوق والحريات
هؤلاء الذين تم اعتقالهم ارهابيين
ولابد ايضا ان يحاسبوا بالقانون ولكن لم
نترك تونس لقمه
لهؤلاء المجرمين
الارهابيين الذين يريدون التنكير بالشعب
التونسي وفي حين بدت هذه الاعتقالات فصلا
جديدا من فصول الصراع بين الرئيس سعيد
ومعارضيها فانها ايضا تعمق من خلافه مع
اتحاد الشغل اكبر المنظمات النقابيه في
البلاد مسالفه ناصي الجزيره تونس
وينضم الينا من تونس كل من احمد الغلوفي
الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي وكذلك محمد
امين الجربي عضو تحالف حراره اهلا بهما
ابدا بالسيد محمد امين جربي لماذا لا تبدو
هذه الاعتقالات مقنعه لاحد سوى للرئيس قيس
سعيد
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
مع عدد صغير عليك لانك وكنت رئيس في
برنامج سيناريوهات بقله الثقافه بقله
العمق ولكن تحدث الان على حمله الاعتقالات
حمله الاعتقالات فيها تهمه التامل على امن
الدوله وهذا رئيس نحن ننتظر وختمه ابحاث
الاوليه وننتظر ايضا تصريحات محامي من
اوقفوا لاخذ موقف من كل ولكن كل الناس
تنتظر المحاسبه مثلا موضوع السيد كمال
لطيف الذي الذي بانت قوته على الدوله في
2012 حين تم محاوله اعتقاله
شرطيا بسيارته وتم محاصرته مقر مقر ثم تم
اخلاء اخلاء انهاء
واصلا حسب النقيله من بعض الاطراف التي
كانت نافذه ان السيد كان يقاوم وزير العدل
وقتها نور الدين البحيري في حاكم التحقيق
وايضا كل الكتابات التي نشرت على نفوذه في
العشريه في العشريه الماضيه وفي وقت نظام
الاستبداد هذا السيد يمثل خطرا مثلا
وايضا بعض بعض الاخرى للمعالجين السيد
الرئيس نحن نعرف انهم يسمون
حركه المسار او حركه الانقلاب فهل لم
يقوموا ضده
بالتامل على ما يسمى بالانقلاب انا انتظر
الخط من الابحاث الاوليه فلننظر في
الملفات ونرى ما يرسل لهم وتصريحات محامين
ثم نتحدث على الاقل على بين في انتظار ذلك
الرئيس قيس سعيد الغلوفي اتهم هؤلاء
بالارهابيين وبالمجرمين مثلما تابعنا
ويعتقد بان عليهم الان ان يقفوا امام
المحاسبه هل هل تراها مقنعه هذه الاتهامات
السؤال نعم سيدغلو فيه
تحيه لك اولا ولمشاهديك اهلا وسهلا يجب ان
نضع هذه التهمه وما هذه الاحداث في سياقها
السياسي وفي سياقها التاريخي اخ محمد انت
تعلم اكثر مني بالتاكيد ان تهمه التعامل
على امن الدوله التجا لها النظام في تونس
تقريبا في ثلاث مناسبات 62 63 ازمه
الشرايطي ثم 78 ثم الان اذن انت تعلم جيدا
مره اخرى ان هذه التهمه تلتجا لها الابظمه
السياسيه الغير الديمقراطيه في العوالم
المتخلفه في حالات النزع الاخيره وفي
حالات الاحتقان الشديد الاجتماعي وفي
حالات المشروعيه السياسيه واعتقد ان يعني
نظام قيس سعيد يعني اكل ضربه في مقتل بعد
17 ديسمبر ونزعت عنه كل شرعيه قانونيه او
دستوريه ونزع عنهما كان يدعي من مشروعيه
الشعبيه حيث لم يذهب الا عدد قليل جدا من
تسعه مليون ناخذ اذا هذا هو السياق العام
انها عمليه تغطيه اثاره غبار شعبوي من قبل
هذا او ذاك نقبض على هذا وكلام يعني مرسل
والقيل والقال الذي لا يثبت يعني قانونيا
هذا اولا ثانيا الرجل تحول الى قاضا انت
رايت ان من مقر وزاره الداخليه
قال مجرمون
ارها
بي وقال يتامرون اذا اين قارئه
اين دور القضاء وكانه يوجه القضاء والقضاه
الذين يسميهم شرفاء بان ينفذوا ما نطقه هو
من احكام
بعد اذنك بعد اذنك فقط هناك مساله مهمه
اريد ان اسال عنها السيد الجربي انت اشرت
فقط للسيد كمال لطيف وهو رجل اعمال كما
يوسف ولكن هناك معتقلون اخرون
مثلا نور الدين بوطار هو مدير اذاعه خاصه
لم يسال الا عن الخط التحريري للاذاعه
وهذا وهذا امر غريب السيد خيام التركي لم
يسال الا عن غداه عمل واتهم وهذا اتهام
غريب بانه مسؤول عن اختفاء مواد غذائيه
مثل القهوه والسكر وهذه مساله ربما مضحكه
يعني
الان لا اتحدث على بيننا ولكن ساتحدث عن
تحليل خاص وارجو ان تعديلني في هذا
هناك مؤامره فيها جناح مالي وجناح اعلامي
وجناحي نعرف ان الجناح المالي وهناك جناحي
وهناك جناح اعلامي وهذه كلها من العناصر
اي مؤامره ومن عناصر ايتامر على امن
الدوله فقدان بعض السلع الاساسيه وايضا
كما استراحت وزاره التجاره انا 5% من
الاطلاع التي تدخل في سوق الجمله نعرف ان
هناك ازمه عالميه
ولكن ايادي الاحتكار موجوده وبالتالي اصلا
حين تخرج المعونه الليبيه الى تونس فجاه
وجدنا كل المواد الاساسيه موجوده وموجوده
في الاسواق هذا لا يلفي انه لا يوجد هناك
احتكار وهذا لا ينفي ايضا ان الاحتكار
موجود وان محركوه سياسيين
لاسباب شعبيه
نعم هناك ايضا عنصر مهم وهو المواقف
الدوليه اسال عنها السيد الغلوفي سواء
الخارجيه الامريكيه او الاتحاد الاوروبي
هل هل يمكن ان تؤثر هذه المواقف في التوجه
المقبل للسلطه
يعني لكي نجيب على هذا السؤال يجب ان نعرف
الرجل ونعرف حقيقه من اتى به ومن كان وراء
25 يعني لا يمكن ان نت
وقع يعني صغيره في العالم الثالث يقوم
رئيسه بمقام به في 25
ويبطل الدستور ويبطل المؤسسات
ويخرب مثل ما اراد دون ضوء اخضر من جهه ما
لذلك اعتقد ان كل هذا الذين اسمعه ولقد
سمعناه طويلا ولا يجب ان نعول عليه اطلاقا
كل ما يحدث وكل هذه التصريحات هي لغير
الرمان في العيون الداخليه في تونس واتجاه
رايهم يعني العام هناك في
رد الغربيه ولكن
ان الرئه به لعده مهام اولها يعني فرض
الاصلاحات
شكرا شكرا جزيلا
معذره لك معذره سيد احمد الغلو في شكرا لك
سيد محمد امين جربي شكرا لك ايضا الان الى
لؤي محمود واخر اخبار الرياضه